SPEAKER 1: Today,
we have the pleasure
of having to Mick
Ebeling talk to us.
He was raised in a
family of entrepreneurs
and philanthropists.
And he's the founder of the
Not Impossible Foundation,
a nonprofit organization that
develops creative solutions
to real world problems,
as well as, The Ebeling
Group, an international
production
company and creative
think tank, representing
some of the world's
leading design
and directing collectives.
He was recently honored
as one of the top 50 Most
Creative People of 2014 and
received the 2014 Muhammad Ali
Humanitarian of the Year award.
He actually lives right here
in Los Angeles with his wife
Caskey and three children.
Let's give a warm
welcome to Mick.
[APPLAUSE]
MICK EBELING: Nice to be here,
you guys, nice to meet you all.
How many people
actually live in Venice?
OK, it was good to see you guys
come over in the neighborhood.
We've been here since '95--
'93, '94-- when a lot of people
wouldn't set their feet
upon this area over here.
So how many of you guys know
anything about Not Impossible?
Hopefully-- awesome, I
love that-- brand spanking
new audience.
So I'm going to tell
you guys a little bit
about Not Impossible.
But I'm going to it
through the story
of why the heck I'm even
standing in front of you
guys today.
And it really comes down
to everybody has a story.
Everybody here is sitting
here for a reason.
Everybody is in their
job for a reason.
Everybody is where
they live for reason,
who's married who they
married, or dating who
they're dating for a reason.
But it all kind
of comes back to,
this is my belief,
at least, this kind
of sliding doors thing,
where you just make
certain decisions in your life.
And all of a sudden,
that leads to something
and leads to something.
The reason I'm here today
is because of this guy.
This guy's name is Tempt.
And Tempt, in the
'80s and '90s, was
one of the foremost
graffiti artists.
And he came home from a
run one day and said, Dad,
my legs are tingling.
And that was the
onset of something
called ALS, which now a lot
more people are aware of, thanks
to the Ice Bucket Challenge,
which was a fantastic thing.
But ALS is this horrific
disease that basically-- you
can describe it in
many different ways.
But it's kind of like the blob.
And it moves up your
body and renders
you completely paralyzed.
So one of the most
horrific things about,
though, is that you retain
your sense of feeling.
As opposed to
breaking your neck,
where you can't
feel anything, you
can actually feel like if your
hand is cramped or hot or cold.
And so, it's a really
really gnarly disease.
So, my production company
decided one year, hey, instead
of giving our clients
a bottle of wine
or some fruit basket or
muffin plate or something
that they would like forget
about the second they got it,
let's make a donation
on their behalf.
So we chose the
Tempt One Foundation.
And we chose them just
because of who he was
and what he represented.
And we had just
recently discovered
kind of what this Tempt
guy was all about.
So we went and met with
his father and brother,
and we sat across the table
from them and said, listen,
I want to give you this money.
What are you going
to use the money for?
And his brother said, I just
want to talk to my brother
again.
So I want to give them a device
that helps me talk to him.
And I said, what do you mean?
Because I thought,
at that time, I'd
never been exposed to anybody
who had any kind of paralysis.
Everybody is only
aware of the things
that they're aware of-- kind
of an obvious statement.
But if you have someone in
your in family with cancer,
or if you have someone in your
family who's in a wheelchair,
you kind of understand the
plights and the situations
around those particular people.
I had never been around
anybody who was paralyzed
and who was unable to talk.
So my assumption
was-- and actually,
let me ask people in the room.
How many people
here are aware of,
or been exposed to, or who
have family members of people
who had Trapped In
Syndrome, who were not
able to talk in any way?
OK, yourself, all right.
So how many people here think
that just one of those Stephen
Hawking machines is just
readily available for people?
Right?
Me, I thought that was just
the way that it worked-- no.
And you probably know that
as well-- not the case.
I said, well, why doesn't he
have a Stephen Hawking machine?
Why doesn't he have one of those
machines that Christoper Reeves
or Stephen Hawking or
these other people?
And he said, that's if you have
insurance or you have money,
and we have neither.
I said, well, how do you talk?
And he said, we talk
through a letter board.
We have a piece of paper,
and we run our hand along it.
And when Tempt gets to
a letter, he blinks,
and we write that down,
and then we start again.
So to say, I'm cold,
or my hand is cramped,
or my neck is kinked,
or something like that
is this horrifically
long process
to actually communicate.
And at that time, when I was
exposed, I was flabbergasted.
It was 1995.
And everybody who
works for this company
is very familiar
with Moore's Law.
Everybody is very familiar
with how fast technology
works and evolves.
In that classic commercial
where the person
that puts in a 3D
television on their wall,
and they go outside, and
the bus goes by that says,
New 4-D Television?
That's kind of classic.
That's the way technology works.
So I was flabbergasted that
this guy wasn't communicating.
He had no way to communicate
except for this piece of paper.
So I have a process.
And that process
is that you commit,
and then you figure
out how the hell
you're going to pull it off.
And knowing that there were
people who had these machines,
and knowing, because
my background was
in technology, but from
the standpoint of 3D
and animation and
design and things
like that, I knew
enough about programming
to make myself dangerous.
But I said, listen, here's
what we're going to do.
One, we're going to get Tempt
a machine so he can talk again.
And two, the next time
there's a fundraiser,
which is how I became
aware of Tempt,
next time there's a fundraising
and there's art on the wall,
it's going to his
art on the wall.
He's going to be the one
drawing again, not someone else
drawing again.
And they went, really?
I said, really.
They said, really?
Yes, really.
We high fived, and we hugged.
And then I was like, oh, my
god, what did I just commit to?
I had no idea how I was
going to pull that off.
So what I like to do, and this
is the way that I live my life,
is I love to surround
myself with people
who make me feel stupid.
If you live your life
like that, you're
the guy at the dinner
table-- the guy
or the girl at the
dinner table who's
winning, because everyone
else is smarter than you.
So the end of the night,
when the check comes,
you've learned more
than everybody else.
So I love to invite
brilliant people
and just have conversations
with them and dialogues.
So that's what I did.
I invited all these crazy
hackers and programmers
to my house.
And we had a couple
theories, and we just
started to explore them.
And the theory was
well, wait a second.
What if we started to-- like,
we know we can get him a device.
We know we can go
and we can break down
the insurance
company kind of walls
and get him a Stephen
Hawking machine.
And we did that.
That was something that
just-- I mean, I'm a producer.
So I don't know how to
take no for an answer.
We just kind of kept going and
going and going, until finally,
they said, uncle.
And we got him a device that
allowed him to talk again.
But the second part of
getting him to draw again
was different.
So we said, what if we
use the eye as a way
to kind of that's the tip of
the pencil or the paintbrush,
if you will.
And what if we mapped
the surface of the eye
and kind of flattened that
out, so that he could move,
and that is how he
actually did his keystrokes
or his paintbrush strokes or,
in this case, his spray paint?
And so we came up with
the theory of this is.
It's called the Eyewriter.
And the Eyewriter,
because my heritage
of where I live right
here in Venice Beach,
is made from materials that
you find in Venice Beach--
$8 cheap sunglasses
from the Venice Beach
boardwalk, coat hangers
from my local dry cleaner.
And then we ordered
a web camera.
And we hacked them all together.
And at the end, this
is what happened.
Tempt is the ultimate
graffiti artist.
He's put Los Angeles on the map.
He's always been next level.
He probably is the
most versatile artist.
Tempt is an innovator.
People respect him.
They know who he is.
He's an OG.
He's such a force.
Nobody compares with his style.
He's one of the top
five in the world.
Him being laid up, I
don't think about that.
When you get diagnosed
with ALS, it's
a traumatizing
experience because you're
told you have only
so long to live,
and you will spend your
time completely trapped
inside a body that
doesn't move anymore.
I hate seeing him like that.
There's so many times where he
could have just slipped away.
But he's sticking it in there.
It's all about that
one phone call,
the phone call that I
almost did not pick up.
Mick definitely was
on the other end.
I had to be involved with
Tempt and just helping him.
I had no idea how I was
going to come through
on what I committed to.
Our writing culture was born of
making something from nothing.
I laid in bed, exploding
with ideas that branched out
from that initial concept.
That's when I knew
I wasn't done yet.
So at the end, we had all
these guys at our house,
and we hacked and we programmed
for about two and a half weeks
and ate a lot of pasta
and spaghetti and beer
and came up with this is.
This is the Eyewriter.
And it is as beautiful
as it looks right there.
It's zip ties and
duct tape and coat
hangers and cheap sunglasses.
But at the end of
two weeks, Tempt
drew again for the first time.
And it was this
amazing experience.
And we're all down the parking
lot outside of his hospital.
We kind of kicked his bed
around so he could see out.
We set up a projector.
It was awesome because we
broke into a car lot next door
and then projected it on
the side of a building.
And he drew again.
And he drew, and
everybody high fived.
Then we had some
beers, and it was just
this awesome experience.
And then we went home,
because that was it.
There was no kind of bigger
picture, grander plan.
It was more like we knew
we could have Tempt draw.
So we did it.
We did it because
we could, and we
wanted to help this one person.
And then, we kind of quote,
"woke up" the next day.
And it was "Time Magazine's"
top 50 Inventions of 2010.
And "Gizmodo" called it "8
Incredible Health Inventions
That Transform Lives."
And it's now a part of
the permanent collection
at the MOMA.
And it was-- we were like,
what the heck just happened?
We just did something,
essentially, because we could,
because we wanted to.
And then, it just took
off like wildfire.
We started to think,
wow, is this something
that we should replicate?
Is this is something
that we should do again,
and what did we do, that
we can replicate it?
And so, in the process of
I'm thinking about this,
and is this something
I want to continue,
we got an email from Tempt.
And Tempt's email
said this, "that
was the first time I've drawn
anything for seven years.
I feel like I had
been held underwater,
and someone finally reached
down and pulled my head up
so I could take a breath."
And we got that, and I remember
actually getting that email
and saying, well, I don't know
what we did, or how we did it,
but we've got to figure
out how to do it again.
And we've got to
figure out how to keep
doing this over and over again.
And that was the launch
of this concept from me
of Not Impossible.
Not Impossible was-- it was
the culmination of me looking
at things that-- I knew Stephen
Hawking had this device,
and I knew that it existed.
But why didn't it exist for him?
And I knew that there was
these things out there.
So how could we take
something that's
impossible for one person,
and make it not impossible?
And what would happen if
there was other things
out there like that?
And because of my
infatuation with technology,
I said well, wait a second.
What if we take technology, and
we make it not just technology
for technology's
sake, but technology
for the sake of humanity?
What happens if we churn
this into something
that we use technology and
we hack and crack and make
and reprogram and
bust open things,
and actually churn it into
something that accomplishes
a fundamental social good?
Then, what could happen?
And so in this obsession
with technology,
I started to obsess about
this concept of impossible
and started to look at,
well, what is impossible?
Well, the reality
is you can't name
anything that was not impossible
at one time-- nothing.
Go for the obvious.
Look around this room-- from
projectors and computers
and cellphones and kind of
the obvious stuff, right?
Now let's go back
a couple hundred,
a couple thousand years.
How about clothes?
Just the concept of
clothes or woven clothes.
Depending on your religious
beliefs, go back even further.
How about walking upright?
So everything, truly
everything-- and everybody
in this room knows this.
How many things did you
guys launch this month that
were impossible last month?
How about this week?
How about today?
You guys do this.
You guys are almost immune
to it at this point.
And we, I think, as a
society, are immune to it,
especially, in the
technology space.
Well, then, if that's the
case, then impossible really
isn't a question of 'if,' it's
a question of a 'when.' So
in this kind of obsession, I
started looking at different
things.
and one of the case studies
that I love to kind of site
is what impossible
incites in people
is this sense the permission.
And this guy is a guy
named Roger Bannister.
And Roger Bannister, in 1954,
was the first human being
in all of recorded
history to ever break
the four-minute mile.
All of recorded history
is a big amount of time.
We've been recording history
for a couple years now, right?
He breaks it on May
6, I think, of 1954.
Within 60 days, two more
people broke that record.
All of recorded
history-- nobody.
He breaks it-- two more
people, including himself,
breaks that record.
So once impossible
becomes possible,
it's a sense of permission
that's granted to everybody.
And everybody goes and does it.
And that's just, again,
that's not rhetoric.
That's statistics.
That's factual data.
So for us, as human beings,
when we look at things,
and we look at things
especially in things
that are helping
other human beings,
maybe it's not possible now.
Maybe pure water's
not a possible now.
Maybe this, that, and the other.
It's just a question of time.
Look at all the
medical inventions
that are coming out nowadays.
The guy that discovered the
test for pancreatic cancer.
He's a high school kid.
So these things
are just a question
of time, which I find
incredibly motivating, in terms
of anything that we
set our sights on.
So Tempt is kind of Act One
or Chapter One, if you will,
of the Not Impossible story.
Chapter Two happened
on July 11--
again, a Venice Beach story--
at a restaurant right over
on Abbot Kinney.
I was out to dinner
with somebody.
And we started
talking about things.
And we started talking
about this guy.
This guy's name is
Doctor Tom Catena.
And this guy I'm
out to dinner with
said, yeah, this guy's amazing.
He's this doctor in
Sudan in this area
called the Nuba Mountains
and blah, blah, blah.
And we start
talking, so I do what
every self-respecting
human being
does at the end of
an interesting night.
You go back and
you look up online
and you Facebook them, right?
So I go back and
look at this guy,
and I read this
story by Alex Perry
that talks about this doctor.
And this doctor is alone
in the Nuba Mountains,
and he is treating these people.
And this Nuba Mountains
is-- has everyone here been
educated in the United States?
Who hasn't been educated
in the United States?
So you guys probably
know where Sudan is.
For for those of you who are
educated in this country,
you probably don't know.
So Sudan is located in a country
called Africa-- or a continent
called Africa.
But it's a contested--
Nuba Mountains
is the contested area
between Sudan, which is kind
of North Sudan and South Sudan.
And it's one of the
most recent countries.
It was July-- I
think it was July 11.
Yeah, July 11 in
2011, I think is when
they received independence.
So there's this war going on
between North Sudan, or Sudan,
and South Sudan.
They declare independence
and the Nuba Mountains
gets the raw of the deal.
Because when they
draw the lines,
the Nuba Mountains
have been fighting
on the side of the south.
But when they're in
the negotiation table,
they said, oh, let's just
move that line this way.
And Sudan got screwed.
Or I'm sorry, the Nuba
Mountains got screwed.
They got put in essentially
the camp, or the country,
that they had been fighting.
So the government
of Sudan-- I promise
this isn't a political-- this
isn't a Michael Moore talk,
I promise.
So the government of
Sudan then implemented
a classic military
approach, which
is you bomb, burn, and pillage.
You drive everybody out.
And then.
When your ground forces come in,
no one's there and you go, oh.
And you plant your flag and say,
looks like there's no one here
to fight.
So they've been constantly
bombing this area.
Well, this doctor
named Doctor Tom
is treating all of the people.
He's the only doctor
within a 1,500 mile radius.
And he's treating
all these people.
He does, literally,
everything, from drawing
blood to appendectomies, to
crazy complicated surgeries,
to really simple surgeries,
and delivering babies.
And he's this incredible guy.
Well, when the war
broke out, his bosses
basically said, hey,
you've got to get out.
It's gnarly over there.
And he said, I'm a
missionary doctor.
This is what I do.
I don't run when it gets tough.
That's when I stay.
And so, he stayed.
And so I'm like, this is
incredible to learn about him.
Well, the gnarly part
about it is the way
that this war works is
that the government,
in that military tactic
of driving people out,
they just constantly do
these bombing missions.
And they roll
55-gallon drums filled
of jet fuel and shrapnel--
metal shrapnel-- out
of the back of prop planes.
So you want to talk
about precision bombing?
This is the antithesis of that.
They roll these things out.
Well, when they hit the ground,
they spray shrapnel everywhere.
So the good thing, if
there is such a thing
as a good thing about a bomb,
is that if you're below ground,
if you get into a foxhole-- and
there's foxholes everywhere--
you're good.
Because as long as you're not
in the path of the shrapnel,
then you're OK.
And the dust settles
and people come up.
And the people are
so resilient, they
actually grab parts
of the shrapnel
and use them for farming tools.
That's kind of how
resilient the Nubans are.
So part of this story
that I read in "Time"
was this young boy
named Daniel was out
tending his family's herd,
and he heard the bomb come.
And he looked around.
There wasn't a foxhole,
so he hid behind a tree.
And he wrapped his arms
around a tree like this.
And the bomb went up not
far from where he was.
And the tree protect his body,
but it blew off his arms.
So this is at 11
o'clock at night.
This is the image.
I come back from dinner,
and I'm reading this,
and I'm learning this.
And this is the
image that I see.
And I'm just kind
of sitting there
a bit aghast, a bit shocked.
I wasn't really expecting this.
And where I'm sitting
at my kitchen table,
I'm looking down
the hallway where
these three knuckleheads sleep.
And this thing in the article--
the very end of the article--
Daniel said when he woke
up, Doctor Tom saved them.
He stitched him up.
And when Doctor Tom saved
him, when Daniel woke up
he said, if I realized
he was an armless boy,
he said, if I
could die, I would,
because now I'm going to be
such a burden to my family.
And I don't know how many
people here are parents in here,
or have nieces and nephews,
or just likes kids.
But the concept of a
kid wishing that they
could die because
they're going to be
a burden to an adult, for
me, was just like, ooh.
And especially, I couldn't
imagine these guys saying that.
So my process kicked in.
I'm like, I don't know
what I'm going to do,
or how I'm going do it, but
I've got to do something.
So in my research
around Not Impossible,
I had launched Not
Impossible labs.
In Not Impossible
labs, we started
to celebrate other
people who we thought
were just doing crazy stuff, who
are inventing things or doing
things or hacking things.
And we had just done
a story on a guy
who had 3D printed a
hand out in Africa.
And we were like, OK,
good, there's something.
We've got something here.
So again, surround
yourself with people
that make you feel stupid.
I borough in a bunch
of people to my house.
We moved all of our stuff out.
We moved out into
the back, again,
like we did for the Eyewriter.
We started cooking lots of
carbohydrates for everybody
all weekend long.
And we started to hack.
And we went through, and we
started to 3D print things,
and sort of to play with
different types of prosthetics.
And we invited owners
of 3D printing companies
and started to look at do we
use plastic, or do we use wood?
This is the carpenter
from South Africa
who first made the robohand, the
hand that we did a report on.
And so I knew that
something out there
had been done in this space.
The end of our
hacker weekend, it
was an utter and
absolute failure.
We had not reached-- we
didn't do anything right.
One of the people
that we invited over
to do a test arm for, she
was missing a right arm,
and we made a left arm for her.
It was just like a parade of
horribles all weekend long.
But we learned what didn't work.
That's for sure.
So Richard said,
listen, mate, I know.
I see that look in your eye.
I know that you're
not not going.
And I said, tickets are bought.
I'm going no matter what.
It's just a question
of whether I'm
going to go out there and
actually get anything done.
He said, look, reroute your
trip through South Africa.
So I went to South Africa
and stayed with Richard
for about seven days.
And we just printed all day,
all night, played with it.
I made more wrong hands and
arms than you could imagine.
But I started to
get the hang of it.
And he showed me the ergonomics
of the hand, how it worked.
And then I bid his family
farewell, hopped on a plane,
and flew from Johannesburg to
Nairobi, and then from Nairobi
to this runway.
And this runway is in Yida.
And Yida is a
refugee camps that's
very close to the border of the
Nuba Mountains and South Sudan.
And this is where all
the Nubans flee to.
And then I got a chance
meet Daniel, the young boy.
The plan was to go
over after meeting him.
We land, I go meet him.
I was incredibly nervous
about meeting this kid.
This entire project was
called Project Daniel.
And this is everything
we've been working towards,
everything we've
been trying to do.
Go meet him, talk to
him for a little bit,
and then hop in a truck
and drive about eight,
nine hours illegally
across the border
with the SPLA, which is the
Sudanese People's Liberation
Army.
They're going to guide us and
help to kind of get across
the border under
the cover of night,
and to Doctor Tom, who's on
the other side, who's actually
in the Sudan region.
So we went over,
and we met, and we
talked to him for a little bit.
There's a problem, though.
We packed up all the
trucks to get ready.
The security showed up and said,
listen, we're from the SPLA,
and you can't go.
And we said, what do
you mean we can't go?
And they said, we're sorry,
but the ceasefire ended.
So it's an active war
zone out there right now,
and we just don't feel
comfortable with you going.
And I did what every
self-respecting producer
in Los Angeles would do, which
is, maybe you don't understand.
I'm on a schedule.
I brought some guys wit
cameras, some printers,
and some laptops, and
we're going to go up there,
and we're going to do this.
So if you can just--
And he's like,
maybe you don't understand.
There's bombs and bullets
going on out there,
and you're not going anywhere.
So we spent about an
hour freaking out.
Like this whole mission
kind of crashed to a close.
Our whole thing was
to get to Doctor Tom
and help Doctor Tom come
up with a methodology
that he could start to
do this for other people.
So we're like, oh, what
are we going to do?
What are we going to do?
And luckily, one of
the local nonprofits
in the area, the
NGO, said hey, look,
while you guys get
this stuff sorted out,
we've got a shed in the back.
If you want to work over in our
shed, then you can get going.
I said, great, let's do it.
So we said, look, let's
start doing this now.
We'll start teaching
people here now.
And let's at least
get an arm for Daniel.
So we went over, and we
started setting up the shed.
In the shed, AKA an
oven, because it was
100-and-something degrees out.
And we just started working with
the cast and the forms of what
we were doing.
And getting to know
Daniel a little bit.
When I first met him,
he was pretty much
silent, didn't want to talk.
And starting to get to
know him a little bit,
and kind of who he was.
And then we learned
the same TIA,
which is This Is
Africa, which is
the equivalent of Murphy's Law.
Literally, if that
could go wrong, it did.
The electricity was wrong.
The electricity spiked.
It was so hot.
Everyone here is-- I'm
assuming at Google,
everyone here is fairly familiar
with how a 3D printer works,
right?
Tube of cold plastic goes
through extruder that heats it
up too hot plastic, turns
plastic to hot frosting,
grid, repeat.
Problem-- if cold plastic is
so hot that cold plastic melts
to itself before it
gets to extruder,
cold plastic can't
go through piece
to make cold
plastic, hot plastic,
and it all melts to itself.
So it was so hot there that my
filament was melting to itself.
And it was just fouling up
every print we were doing.
So we had to start
printing at night.
That's started to
work a little bit.
But then, we had
problems with that
because most of these
printers give off light.
Light attracts what?
Bugs.
Bugs in Africa are
a little bigger
than bugs in Venice Beach.
So I have these dive-bombing
pterodactyl-size moths
hitting my printer and
jamming up my printer
so that I couldn't
actually print.
So it was one thing after
another after another.
But it's called Project Daniel.
And this is what I
woke up to every day
was Daniel sitting next to me.
So try-- everybody
repeat after me.
Imagine Daniel
sitting next to you
and try saying,
sorry, Daniel, we're
not going to be able
to do this for you.
Yeah, you can't say it.
It's impossible, right?
I don't believe in impossible.
That I believe is impossible.
So we just kind of kept
fighting through it.
And then after kind of all
kinds of trials and tribulations
and mess ups, this
is what happened.
There's this thing
in me that loves
to see things that are not
supposed to be done, be done.
Daniel is just one of
50,000 amputees left
in the wake of the bloodiest
war Africa has ever known.
We flew into an active
war zone in Sudan
with 3D printers, laptops,
spools of plastic,
and the goal to
build Daniel an arm.
You ready?
The concept of Project Daniel
was hatched on July 11th.
And on November 11th, Daniel
fed himself for the first time
in two years.
But it's never about
just one person.
If we could teach the
locals to do it themselves,
then Project Daniel could
live on long after we left,
and it did.
So that's Project Daniel.
And that's what happened, which
was take the first time Temp
drawing, on that kind of night
down in downtown Los Angeles.
And then take the moment
where Daniel fed himself
for the first time.
And then that moment in the
room where he's actually
throwing stuff to Doctor Tom.
It was a pretty awesome,
awesome experience.
So what I did around
this was essentially
a conclusion of you could go
about this a couple different
ways, right?
You could go about this
acting like a nonprofit,
or you could go about
this and actually
get corporations and
companies to get something out
of the process of
changing the world.
So my philosophy around
this, now, what I do
is I believe that brands
can change the world.
I believe that brands can change
the world because human beings
run those brands.
Human beings run
those corporations.
And I started off
as a nonprofit.
And I used to joke
with my friends,
I was getting carpal tunnel
from like shaking the tin
can all the time, trying
to people through a couple
shekels in.
And I wasn't really
get anywhere.
And I spent most of my
time trying to figure out
how to get people to
give me money as opposed
to doing the work.
And then I realized,
well, what would
happen if I actually
started to think about this
in a completely different way?
And the different way is
this-- and Fuller says it
the best-- is that, if you
want to change something,
don't go about it by just
taking a new tack on things.
You have to clear the
slate and start it
from a completely new approach.
And that's what we did.
And so what we started
to do is say, well,
what happens if we got
brands, who already--
and especially this company.
You guys understand this.
People and brands have a
message that they have to tell,
and they tell it in a
variety of different ways.
Well, what would happen if we
gave brands an incredible story
that they could tell.
And they could say,
yes, we want to give you
money to go tell this story.
But this story is, instead of
being a comedian telling a joke
or a fictitious commercial
that's being made
or contest or
something like this,
what if it was something
that's really truly changing
the world?
That's something that brands
can sink their teeth into.
And that's something that
the people of those brands
can sink their teeth into.
So that's what we did, is
we got Intel and a company
called Precipart to get
behind Project Daniel.
And then, we launched
Project Daniel.
And we launched Project Daniel
actually a week ago last week
on January 6th, ironically, the
exact day that the book came
out, which was nice,
nice serendipity.
And it launched, and
we got 420 million
earned media impressions in
14 weeks with zero paid media.
It was purely from
just people being
amazed by the
story really seeing
the story as a valuable thing.
And everybody in the
world covered it.
That's the value that Intel got.
That's the value
that Precipart got.
And that's the value
that the world got,
because now, the world
got a piece of code,
and they got a manuscript, and
they got some instructables,
and they got a
how-to video on how
to actually make this thing.
Because everything we
do at Not Impossible,
our theory is not IP.
Our theory is not,
let's make something
and let's go be the
biggest 3D printing
prosthetic maker in the world!
It's like, no, give it away.
Because, the arm that we made,
and we launched a year ago,
that arm has been bested
probably four or five times
over since then.
Because our job was to
start to light the fuse,
and then let people run with it.
When we made the
Eyewriter, we lit the fuse,
and the Eyewriter's almost
obsolete at this point
because you can
now-- the devices
that existed were $15,000.
We made it for $90.
Now you can get
beautiful devices
for $200 that are off-the-shelf,
that come in a nice box
and have customer support.
And not some hacker
over in Venice Beach
that put some stuff together.
So that's what
we're trying to do.
We're trying to incite and
provoke this type of change.
And that's what we were
able to do around this.
And we launched this
thing, and then, it
accomplished everything
that we wanted
it to do as far as media goes.
Added a day, and then it
started winning awards, Telly.
And we got Best of
Show at the One Show.
And AICP created a
special award for us.
And we won at the
next awards for there.
At Cannes, which is kind of
the big advertising festival,
we won the granddaddy of them
all, which is the Titanium.
And this was all about a story
about us going out and doing
good with technology.
So what this concluded
for us is-- not
concluded, what it just proved
to us is that our theory is--
everyone's heard the theory
doing good is good business.
Everyone's aware of that.
And everybody in this
room, most likely,
makes decisions on purchases
based on whether they
know a company is doing good.
But doing good is
also good branding.
And if we can actually take--
what Not Impossible wants to do
is take all these different
initiatives that we're
doing right now,
and match them up
with corporations who
can get the word out,
because your company and other
companies like your company,
you have this massive, massive
megaphone that nonprofits
don't have access to.
And at the end of the day, I'm
judging us by whether or not
we're doing good in the world.
And whether we do
good in the world
is measured by how powerfully
our message gets out there.
And I absolutely believe
in the power of the story.
The story that we
told was about-- this
is a critical point
to this, as well.
Well, usually I say,
there's probably
nobody in this room with
the net worth of Bill Gates.
But I'm at this company, so
I can't make that assumption.
Maybe some of you have
been here a long time.
But most people don't have
Buffett or Gate's type net
worth.
So you can't attack things
like hunger or malaria
or things like that.
As noble and as
amazing and those are,
how do you wrap your arms
around the concept of malaria
as a single human being?
Or hunger, how do you wrap
your arms around that?
But if I said, there's a dude
outside that needs a sandwich.
Can you loan me $5 or
just run and pilfer one
from the a Google cafeteria?
Can you hook me up?
Do you want to do that?
The answer is yes.
If I say, hey, can
you really quickly,
I need to solve world hunger.
Do you want to help me out?
You're like, uh.
So the powerful
thing is the power
of one story about one person is
what we base our philosophy on.
Our philosophy is
help one, help many.
You help one person.
But by helping that one
person, has the potential
to help many, many people.
And that's through
the power of story.
So we go through and we tell
stories about this all the time
on Not Impossible now.
We're constantly telling
stories about things.
We just ran at CES
having our minds
blown about all these
incredible people who
are out there doing incredible
things around technology.
But we're not so interested
in the 70-million-inch curved
plasma, as we are in
these different devices.
We're like, oh,
interesting, what
if we took that and
matched it up with that,
and then matched that with that.
And then, krchk, we Frankenstein
something that can actually
accomplish something amazing.
So the question that
we ask to you guys,
and the question that
I ask to my readers,
ask to the people who
are familiar with Not Impossible
is, what's your story?
What's your story, and even more
importantly, who is your one?
Who is that one person, what's
that one invention, what's
that one thing that
you can do that
can lead to something
that can help
many, many people
around the world?
And ultimately, that's
who is your Daniel.
So help one, help many.
Thank you, guys, very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
you stay for questions?
MICK EBELING: Sure, absolutely.
SPEAKER 1: I have a couple of
technical questions, actually.
MICK EBELING: Uh, oh,
I'm not the tech guy.
I'm going to preface
that right now.
AUDIENCE: But on
the Eyewriter, I'm
just wondering, when you your
drawing something by blinking
your eyes around as
the brush, and then you
want to look at
what you've drawn,
how do you avoid
scratching over?
MICK EBELING: It's
a great question.
So there's two ways to engage
ocular recognition technology--
and I'd never said those
three words in a row
prior to the Eyewriter, ocular
recognition technology-- blink
and gaze.
So the way the Eyewriter worked
is that Tempt was laying there,
and he would stare,
and he would blink,
and that puts the pencil down.
And he would blink, and that
would pick the pencil up.
So you would just blink and
pick it up, and then move or do
what you want to do, and figure
out where you want to go again.
And blink and set it down again.
And his skills as an artist-- I
can barely draw a stick figure.
What he was able to do with
his eyes and essentially
a two-dimensional application
with a pencil and a paper,
essentially what
it was, what he was
able to create
three dimensionally,
was-- there's actually some
pictures of it in the book.
You can see it.
It's remarkable.
AUDIENCE: Very cool.
The other one was just how--
when Daniel was throwing
the ball-- how was that--
MICK EBELING: This
is awesome, OK?
Everybody put your hand out
in front of you like this.
Now, at the tip of your fingers
you've got guitar strings.
Those are tight
guitar strings, right?
And it runs down your
hand, on your wrist,
around to the fulcrum point of
your elbow, and to your bicep.
Now go like this.
What happens to
those guitar strings?
They get tighter.
And what happens if
they get tighter?
What happens to your
fingers if these are hinged?
They have to.
If they don't, if this is all
fixed, and you go like this,
you're not going to
be able to bend it.
So something has to give.
So you go like this.
It pulls on the strings
and your hand collapses.
So the concept of
throwing something-- I'm
looking for something to throw.
Here, ready?
So I'm going to pick this up.
I put my hand across like this.
I put my hand over it.
It took Daniel all of maybe
13 seconds to figure this out,
too.
It was incredible.
You put your hand over it.
You bend your elbow like this.
It goes like this.
Now watch this.
I'm going to throw this.
Watch my arm, OK?
So it's bent.
It's collapsed.
The strings are pulled.
Ready?
This is a pitcher.
Arm's bent.
Arm's straight with
my fingers open.
So he drilled three
perfect passes to us
with ball of Ace bandage.
And we were like, what
the hell is going on?
Is this kid like a
test tube quarterback
that we've discovered him?
It's like Manute Bol discovering
him in some foreign land
and then bring him back?
And it's no-- it's just a
natural physiology of a throw.
It's like this, like
this, then you release.
So his fingers opened up.
So he threw it to Doctor
Tom and me a couple times.
It was like perfect throws.
AUDIENCE: So the power
then actually came
from his shoulders.
The arm itself was not powered?
MICK EBELING: The arm's
not powered at all.
It's completely
man-- it's strings.
We looked at
different ways that we
might be able to create
things with power.
And you put something
in a village
where there's no
power, no electricity,
and you've got a
feeble machines that's
going to last as long as a
bunch of first world countryites
are there.
And as soon as they
leave, it's going bust.
So the way we did it is
we tried to make it so
that, oh, a string breaks?
Great, restring it.
Oh, a finger breaks?
Great, reprint it.
We tried to make it
as simple as possible.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
MICK EBELING: Absolutely.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I just want to
know, essentially,
what are you up to next?
Like, what's the thing
that's keeping you up
at night now [INAUDIBLE]?
MICK EBELING: Hmm, no one ever
asked that question before.
It's almost like I have
slides prepared for that.
She's not a plant.
Did you know me before this?
AUDIENCE: No.
MICK EBELING: That wasn't
a planted question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] slides?
MICK EBELING: Yes, I do.
Everyone-- that's kind of a
little game I play in my head.
Like, OK, is it going
to be the first question
or the third question?
Usually in there.
So I got taken, a while ago,
right after Project Daniel
launched in April
of last year, and I
got taken to hospital or
a rehabilitation hospital
in Mexico City.
And they took me, and it's
just this incredible pediatric
rehabilitation center.
And at the end of my tour,
they showed me this room.
And this room was kind of all
their gadgets and whatnot.
And this is a little
girl named Pia.
And she's on a treadmill,
hanging from straps,
and she's got these little,
elliptical like robots
on the side of her legs.
And what this is, is
she's got cerebral palsy.
And when you have
cerebral palsy--
in my very unmedical
definition of cerebral palsy--
it's the bridge
between the brain
and the muscles isn't fire.
So the act of me
saying I'm going
to walk, I just told my legs to
do that, and I do it naturally,
right?
But there's no firing there.
It's not firing down to
tell the legs what to do.
So what this does, is it
kind of reverses the signal,
and it starts to show her brain
the other way like, hey, this
is what it feels like to walk.
So like a DJ, you kind
of cross-fade it down.
And over the period
of a year, she
starts to learn what it
means to be ambulatory.
And it's awesome.
And the human body is
just an incredible thing.
So I'm watching this thing,
and I'm like, this is amazing.
And we went out to lunch.
The guy that ran this hospital,
who's incredible human being,
we went out afterwards and I
said, man, this is amazing.
I love that last thing
that you just showed me.
But my question is, with
as many kids as you see--
and they saw-- I got there
at about noon for my tour.
And they had already
seen, by noon,
1,200 kids in this facility.
So I said, with as many kids
as you see, why don't you
have just rows of
these things and just
like literally just pumping
people through these things.
Because if you use this,
they said, that the kid
can walk in a year.
And if they don't, it could
take five years, if even.
And with the
classic parallel bar
and with the physical
therapist right down
and working with them.
It's very kind of one-on-one.
He says, I'd love to
have that, but they're
half a million dollars each.
And so, who are the
technical people in here?
Who's on the programing side?
You guys know the MasterCard
'priceless' campaign?
Treadmill, $200.
Climbing straps, $40
brand new at REI.
You guys want to take a shot
at how hard it would be to just
create something to like this?
Try, try as hard as you might
to try to get that price up,
and I couldn't get it up.
So I said to him-- remember
the whole commitment,
figure it out?
I had a voice in my head.
Its was like, be careful.
You didn't know jack about
optical recognition and 3D
printing, but this one
might be a little bigger.
And I ignored the voice.
And I said, all right.
How about this.
Let's say I can make this thing
for you for under $100,000?
And he said, I'd by
20 of them from you.
And I went, all right,
I'll be right back.
And this-- actually,
this week is a huge week
because we're finalizing some
of the partnerships around this.
But we are going to create a
low-cost ambulatory exoskeleton
called-- all of our initiatives
are called What They Do,
Not Impossible.
So this is called
Walk Not Impossible.
And we're going to create
this thing so that we
can do exactly what we
did with the Eyewriters,
exactly what we did
with Project Daniel.
And our goal is to get,
within three years,
over 1,000 kids walking
again for the first time.
And the coolest
thing about it is
that in the room that I
built of all the people
that made me feel
stupid, one of my friends
said, hey, if you ever do this
again, my son is a programmer.
Can he come and he'll
just like go get you guys
waters and things like that?
And we said, sure,
yeah, come on over.
His name's Joel.
I was at-- when he was born.
I've known him his whole life.
And so he kind of sat
quietly in the room.
At the end of all of these
really smart people with lots
of initials behind their name
talking, he raised his hand
and said, hey, do you
mind if I share something?
I've got a couple ideas.
And we went , sure,
Joel, go ahead.
Go ahead, go ahead.
And he just dropped knowledge
on us for about three minutes
straight.
And the sound of everyone's
jaws just going ooh,
ooh, ooh, as he dropped it.
And I'm proud to tell you that
the Granada Hills High school
robotics team are the
lead manufacturers
and hackers on this assignment.
And they are blowing
people's minds right now.
It's just incredible.
So we actually--
Wednesday, we are
going to be filming our
prototype going live
for the first time.
We hope to be an alpha.
That will be the prototype.
And the one thing is
I didn't tell the guy
when I went to lunch with them
that I'd be done by December.
But that was kind
of in my own head.
So I'm pissed off that I missed
my deadline by about three
weeks to have this thing done.
But we'll have our
prototype this week.
We'll hopefully have alpha
within 30 to 45 days.
We'll go into beta
with Cornell Medical
back east with a thing called
Burke Rehabilitation Hospital.
They're looking at
partnering with us
just in some of our trials.
One of our amazing allies and
volunteers works back there.
And then, we're going to
try to blow this thing out
to the world.
So that's next thing we're
working on right now.
We're we launch this
week or next week,
another iteration of a
communication device for people
who have Trapped In Syndrome.
And it came, actually,
a introduction
through a bunch of
Googlers, actually,
up in the San Francisco office.
I met a guy named Alan Yu.
And Alan heard me talk at the
Exploratorium in San Francisco,
and came up afterwards
and said, we
have this thing called the--
you guys do 20 Percent, right?
He's like we have this
thing called 20 Percent.
I don't know what I can do
around with my 20 Percent,
but I want to try to help you.
And so he just started doing
what is kind of gift is.
And what his blessing
is he started
making introductions to people.
And he introduce
us to some people,
and now HP kind of came on board
to help us with this thing.
And we're launching this
thing called Don's Voice.
Don's been married to
Lorraine now for 25 years.
And he hasn't spoken to her
for 15 because he had ALS.
And he's a farmer.
And he lives a very simple
life in northern or two
hours outside of Canada.
And we basically recreated
his letter board.
You know the letter board
that Tempt was using?
So this is where I
was just like, what?
It was 2013, and Don was
still using a letter board.
And I'm like, you're kidding me?
It sounds very simple, but the
pragmatism around it is very,
kind of, I think, is what
makes it so brilliant.
If I gave all of
you guys a new phone
or new keyboard for
your computers and said,
here you go.
But I changed the order of it.
Would that be like the
most frustrating thing
in the world for you?
Well, if you had a
letter board that you'd
been using your whole life your,
whole kind of paralyzed life,
and it's laid out the
way that your loved one
or caretaker laid it out, that's
what you're used to, right?
That's your keyboard.
That's your interface.
So we basically created
an ocular recognition tool
that lets you customize
your interface so that it
mimics your letter board.
So that when you transition
from the paper route
to the digital route, it's
a very fluid transition.
And that allowed him
to write a love letter
to his wife for the first
time in 15 years, which
was a really awesome story.
So those are two projects that
we're super passionate about.
And that'll launch either
this week or next week.
So, take a look for it.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] makers
of those expensive [INAUDIBLE]
like the walker and the--
MICK EBELING: Not yet.
Not yet, but we give it away.
Like how do you-- yeah,
this is going to broadcast,
so I'm not going to
talk too much smack.
But are mantra is
to give it away.
If it was to harness the IP
and try to make a profit,
then-- I believe in
an original idea.
And I believe that people, if
they come up with something
great, then they should be
able to make money doing it
and build a company around it.
And I don't believe the
people's communication
and mobility should be
hinged by whether or not
they have money or insurance.
So we do it, and then we
put out there to the world.
And if people take it
and make it better,
which they've done on everything
we've done so far then, great.
That's what we
want to see happen.
AUDIENCE: So that leads
to the question, what
is your business model then?
Because I know a lot
of other companies
are trying to get into the
'good' space, like do good.
Yet, their business model
isn't set up to enable that
or Google has 20 Percent.
How does [INAUDIBLE]?
MICK EBELING: It's
a great question.
HP is going to pay
somebody for content.
Now the concept that the
get is an amazing story
around Don and Lorraine Moore.
Intel is going to pay
somebody for their content.
They get a story about a
young boy feeding himself
for the first time in two years.
The robot walker is going
to be an incredible story,
as you can imagine, with
all the different stories
that come out of that, where
kids becoming ambulatory.
We are storytelling company.
That's what we do.
But rather than
funny or die, where
it's about comedy or Michael
Day about exploding things,
our stories are focused
around technology
for the sake of humanity.
And that's kind of how we do it.
And then, we have different
kind of off shoots.
And the business model is
such that Not Impossible Now
is an ad-supported site.
So you can go and
you can just like
you would go to CNET or Vice
or TechRepublic or Gizmodo
and see those things,
now you're seeing
stories that are kind of
focused on that technology
for the sake of humanity.
So, we're growing.
We're growing that side
of the business, as well.
But right now, our
primary is through brands
seeing what we're doing
and going, that's amazing.
How can we get
part of that story?
AUDIENCE: What does
your wife think
about you going to a war zone?
MICK EBELING: So my wife is
co-directing the documentary.
She's an incredible storyteller.
And we both put blinders
on a little bit.
And we're about to
release the cut.
We're about in our final cut.
And now that she saw how
gnarly it was over there,
and she's seen all
the footage, we've
had conversations about
the fact that it probably
wasn't something that would
have been as encouraged.
But it's also, she would
never-- she's incredible.
And she would
never have said no.
And I would never have said no.
Because when you're called
to do something like that,
you get that gut reaction.
And we see incredible
things come across our desk
every single day.
We get voice mails and
emails and Facebook messages
all the time.
And we always are trying to
encourage people to do it.
But when you get hit
in the gut by something
and you know you have
to do it, there's
nothing religious about at all.
It just like, OK
you need to do it,
and that was kind of the
thing with Project Daniel.